updated covid-19 vaccines now available
to most Canadians Target the covid
sub-variants still dominant here but
Health experts are now warning the virus
is changing mutations are happening at
any time in you know randomly and any
part of the world we see now that the
new variants or subarian that they are
popping now they are basically escaping
the immune system in Europe the return
to normal life has sparked the start of
another wave seen as a marker for what
North America can expect next this U.S
expert is watching the climbing cases
closely this time the picture is a bit
muddled because the rise of cases
doesn't seem to be associated with any
one particular variant you are seeing a
rise in ba5 but you're seeing some of
these new I like to call them Scrabble
variants those variants have reached
mutations in the hundreds and while some
die off without much concern others have
recently been added to a new watch list
by the World Health Organization in
Canada omicron's ba5 makes up the
majority the ba5 more closely resembles
the new
Scrabble variants than the original
lineage so you're more likely to get
protected if you've getting that new
bivalent booster Health Canada approved
Pfizer strain specific shot Friday this
week the company confirmed the vaccine
generated a strong immune response but
it did not disclose the levels of
antibodies moderna's bivalent booster
has been approved since early September
still in the last six months just 16
percent of Canadians have been boosted
leaving many prime doctors say to catch
covet again the best policy is to get
vaccinated even if you had infection
advice that's only helpful if vaccines
keep up with covid year after year Jamie
moroccer Global News